tract distribué aux automobilistes dès 7
heures du matin puis une opération
escargot solaire ce soir en direction du
creusot
les entreprises de travaux publics n'ont
pas ménagé leur peine ce matin pour se
faire entendre
la raison de leur colère la hausse du
gasoil combinée à la suppression du taux
réduit de la taxe qui lui est appliquée
cet entrepreneur a déjà prévu
d'augmenter ses prix si on augmente le
prix fort les chantiers cessa pas
évident ce qui peut se passer c'est
est-ce que des collectivités d'autres
mots les collectivités est ce qu'elles
vont suivre notre augmentation qu'on va
leur proposer
je pense qu'elles vont réduire le volume
de travail donc c'est vraiment leur
marche en marche en arrière pour saisir
on n'avance pas on recule
autre moyen pour contourner cette hausse
mieux consommer de carburant
jean-philippe réolon dirige une
entreprise de 20 salariés à autun il
leur a demandé de faire plus attention
jeu des échanges avec eux au niveau de
la consommation en lézard en attirant
leur attention sur le fait qu'il faut
consommer moins pour éviter de trop de
dépenses cette année et 2019 qui va
arriver devrait être une très très bonne
année et là on nous coupait l'herbe sous
le pied donc c'est des investissements
qu'on pourra pas faire et des emplois on
a vraiment besoin de recruter point
d'interrogation baisse des
investissements prévus l'an prochain gel
des embauches
les entreprises de travaux publics de
bourgogne franche comté font grise mine
pionnière du mouvement elle espère être
suivie rapidement par leurs collègues
des autres régions françaises